I'll be talking today a bit about how
we've implemented at a quiz IO over the
last roughly ten months how to use
Wolfram in a cloud as an API type
service to allow us to scale our
business to do lots of calculations I'll
describe what that means and words
continuously and also to help accelerate
how we develop algorithms which are
constantly doing before we even get into
that though one of the things I
discovered over the last many years of
doing this needs to give talks in like
2006 I'm using our with Mathematica and
things we're building systems that would
separate certain computational
complexity away from day-to-day
operations and one of the things that
we've certainly noticed right away and
it's certainly true in our calculations
here is a lot of times you can cast a
calculation as something you're doing
frequently but has coefficients in it
that are updated on a less frequent
scale like once a day once every six
hours something like that and so your
system has two types of calculations you
have one like we do every 30 minutes
which is update a bid we do at Google
it's how much are we currently bidding
at Google right now on that device and
that campaign for that client those are
done millions of times per day across
our clients but things that it uses like
what is the look-back period that I'll
do for looking at data what is the CPC
what is the result of my bidding what am
I trying to pay-per-click across today
values like that change daily they don't
change every 30 minutes and those type
of calculations are examples of type 2
which is calculations which are much
more complicated so the first case is
almost like a series calculation like a
Maclaurin series or something a bit
different same idea and the second one
is we're releasing machine learning to
determine what is the best result takes
a lot more time deals calculations but
still we have to do many thousands
hundred thousand these calculations a
day currently which could take a very
long time the second group are really
good candidates for this technology
and so we're hoping to do is wanted to
one of my dreams always wanted to do is
leverage Mathematica libraries in a
commercial sense on a commercial scale
so how can we actually make use of these
and not have to rewrite all over could a
little scribe in a minute that helps us
really speed up our testing and things
that we're doing this allows us to as
point2 says decouple the algorithm part
of our business away from the rest
because one of the things that were most
afraid of is and I've always seen this
and my work that I've done over the last
almost 25 years I've used Mathematica 26
years since 1990 version two is that I'm
I was afraid of having somebody rewrite
my math who doesn't understand math
that's a very scary thing and lots of
weird areas can come up in your code
when they do that so and we living with
this my whole life so what this allows
us to totally decouple it so we have a
scientist write the Mathematica code
goes directly from concept to production
without being rewritten and then the
scientists computer signed two-storied
all the rest of the plumbing that
connects to that so it keeps the right
actors doing the right jobs and it
greatly expands our ability to test in
production that's really a challenging
thing one of my first revelations in ad
tech internet average sizing technology
in 2005 when I working with red media
was we waited for a data drop from this
company for almost six months after
signing our contract we were going crazy
we don't get paid until we do work so
waiting and waiting and waiting and as
the CTO said Brian O'Kelly is now the
CEO of AB Nexus very large had to come
down to New York it was like changing
airplane engines that airplane in flight
getting the data out of it very hard to
do the reverse approach to that is you
test in production you need to test your
algorithms in production that's the only
place you do real testing
so it's like split stream testing so you
have to have an ability to test many
many algorithms across many many test
groups all in parallel live you can't do
things in the development environment
make-believe environment they're
meaningful you can you can pull data
from Google or Facebook or thing you can
look at it act like you're doing
calculation make sure all that plumbing
works but at the end of the day if you
don't actually do a bid you don't know
what happens in the auction you don't
know if your technology actually works
so the architecture we came up with
which we think is a good solid design is
that we divorced our algorithm work away
from the rest of the company through
restful api everything we're doing on
the algorithm side is totally stateless
so they package up the data of the
hanate to us we do the calculation we
hand them back the answer we forget
about it a lot of good things come of
that horizontal scalability you can
scale out infinitely horizontally
there's no problems with that at all
it's the ultimate example of stupid
parallel we define bills law in that
regard and lets us work independently so
doesn't matter what language you write
in on the right hand side we write in
Mathematica Wolfram language but we
could write in some other language our
Python make up a language you like and
they can do what they need to do in
there so I mean talk to each other
through a standard API we can also
therefore deploy asynchronous to each
other and we don't have to worry about
all of the data persistence issues that
invariably come up this is our
traditional development cycle before
this project I'll go through it real
quickly but we come up with algorithm
ideas we do that all the time you know
they say Google that they do two
algorithm changes a day on average for
Google search to a day not six hundred
some-odd a year how do they do that well
they don't do this that's for sure
they do not do this because what happens
here is you come up with an idea you
have to document it
oh excuse me this is the wrong slide I'm
ahead of myself that's why I'll jump to
this one you come up with an idea your
prototype in Mathematica you create
documentation your team can review he's
got out people reviewing the ideas make
sure the science is right science team
reviews it and then you do the
investment of designing software
documentation now that the non
scientists can use to build the
scientific software that takes weeks or
longer then you have to implement it in
some language not Mathematica not what
foreign language that takes months
usually lennie have to test it which
takes another month and make believe
testing dev when you have to test it in
production which takes weeks or months
and then if you see something is wrong
there's no easy reverse path in most
cases you can turn it off you maybe roll
back to the old algorithm but it's a
very painful path in most cases and QA
testing is very difficult look at how
we're doing it now we skip that whole
part about reinterpreting our work we
write it once we document it we come up
with our ideas we then deploy them into
a dev environment using the existing API
so we're totally asynchronous of normal
development cycles we have an existing
API that's understood we can deploy
hundreds of algorithms against that one
API and all we have to do to deploy it
once we're convinced that it works
reasonably well interact testing which
means it can read when I start actually
start bidding on auctions we deployed to
some limited number of people like one
campaign ten campaigns but I'll wait to
do to deploy does this change the
endpoint in the database so what we're
aiming at that's really powerful so let
you very quickly scale out from an
initial start let you see that whether
it's working or not correctly this
allows you to very quickly if you have a
problem turned it off let's roll back to
the other algorithm let's takes database
change you have to redeploy code or
undeploy code or deal with
issues you can do very limited testing
initially is mentioned what types of
problems might one use this for here's a
couple n I'm gonna list well just real
quickly I look back this is we calculate
we do our work like on bidding how much
we want to bid had forgiven auction in a
given moment on Google let's say we're
looking at it for different devices
mobile not mobile it's a tablet desktop
every campaign has their own end devices
their own look back and we assured us
three hours in these longest 48 days
after everybody so we have hundreds of
thousands these are calculating every
let's say date that's a good example in
these calculations what are we actually
targeting for what we're trying to pay
CPC cost per click across these devices
across campaigns what's your daily
budget how does it vary with campaign I
was very with a group of campaigns that
are sharing it but as the vary by time a
week time of year this is a complicated
calculation there is machine learning
involved then we have all sorts things
we do regarding analysis we're looking
at people's actually ads and seeing what
are they advertising upon looking at
their keywords and seeing what they're
really advertising upon I'll show an
example that it's a great example of
clustering machine learning
classification problem but you have that
across tens of thousands or more
examples you could do it upon and then
of course analysis that your ongoing
here's live data where a couple days ago
this is one of our bigger algorithms you
can see here this is Mathematica stuff I
actually used for the first time one of
these so this shows the pop up there
that we're doing 46,000 and change API
calls on the 10th of October for this
particular algorithm that's quite a few
that's about one every two seconds it's
just one of many that we do do something
here to make this a little bit easier to
see I think maybe this shows in every
single day what for the whole round trip
experience what was the mean execution
time so it's roughly 1.4 seconds a
standard deviation one second roughly
shows that buried in time we did an
Oracle database upgrade here which made
it worse there's some load balancing
issues right there you can see Oracle
database change so the right here shows
actually within Wolfram cloud land what
we're actually doing you know it's very
very stable even as we double triple so
forth our load the actual computation
stay pretty much the same this is the
mean time to do an execution it's
roughly a half second six hundred feel
like 50 milliseconds and the standard
deviation is about half that which is
really good result
sort of surprising this is an on an
eight-core machine up on AWS with
roughly 64 Giga memory running 8 see
where I'm kernels on it but a big part
of those threading well the big things
we discovered too early on which is no
great surprise was nice to verify is
that we get really good pipelining so as
we load up the queue with many many jobs
through threading that the server's are
not next to us makes no difference at
all it's a big vector pipeline so you
just load it up and that transit time
between where we're at Montreal and
where the servers are at New Jersey is
like zero
net effect on the results there is no
price that we see it all that we're
paying we run other cases this is a very
small example of a trial here we're only
running on you know it looks like
sixteen campaigns here this is a very
early one that we're looking at and so
it allows you to look across the system
here's a Bing examples here just I
believe twenty some one thousand jobs
they're running and we do see when we
went to Oracle on Bing that they
suffered more it's roughly 1.3 seconds
one point yeah to five seconds and as
the standard deviation it's very similar
to the other one and this is related to
load balancing and so forth but once
again the Wolfram performance is
impeccable it's really sort of shocking
you see that much growth you're going
here from basically nothing 1,400 to
20,000 that's that's a lot of growth
that's sort of crazy there's one more
example I list here just for
completeness but it's it's smaller Yahoo
Japan so this another client we have we
work for the largest ad agencies in
Japan and this is a small sample of some
of the stuff we're doing with them right
now we're doing roughly a hundred
thousand of these a day computations
calls the API that's roughly three
million a month and it's going to grow
by about a triple in the next three
months roughly which graph this one here
this is good news here this is good news
means
it's it could be load-balancing it could
be configuration related we did upgrades
the system about that I also don't get
excited about 2,000 jobs I care about 30
40 30,000 jobs
I mean sometimes this type of thing it's
so noisy that you're just being misled
but it's not really a feature yeah I
mean I worry more about these type Peaks
here but there's a hierarchy of
publishers as we call them ad AdWords
Google is by far the best the response
time they call their API is about 100
milliseconds something like that
then you go to Bing relatively speaking
being is six times slower per call which
is horrible and then these guys are like
five times slower than that so they're
like 30 times slower than AdWords or 40
depending upon the day it's ridiculous I
guess I shouldn't say more I'll get in
trouble
but it means you have to use a lot more
threads means you have to lose a lot
more scaling and takes more hardware
it's just scary and we talked them all
the time and I'm not sure we're making
any progress
of course yeah who owns them well enough
said they're they're being chopped
chopped so they're being sold to
somebody these are examples that's one
show a few examples type of data that I
look at every day off of these results
this this one enables us to do this one
of our biggest jobs is to almost like eh
oh but it's like the matrix so one of my
jobs every day I spend three hours on or
more I look at the data and look for
things I can't explain look for small
screw-ups we mean every day for an hour
my team and I do is four of us they work
on this specifically looking for
mistakes or phenomenon that just don't
make sense and then I want to make it
better or we see opportunities to make
it faster a lot of incremental changes
cause big changes in cumulative that's
exactly what Google's doing everybody
else here's one graph here that's sort
of easy to understand which is looking
at it's a double graph so it's showing
on the y-axis on the right is clicks
which is the red shade I'm pointing at
so there's nine clicks here and on the
other axis the left axis is what you're
paying
this is cost-per-click yeah ideally want
to see clicks go up costs go down they
call an extra that's not a perfect world
these are this is a small account as i
mentioning here so they're getting nine
clicks - clicks three clicks at various
day-to-day what they're getting we're
bidding or varying our bid throughout
the day we're looking at all sorts of
performance we're looking at here the
blue is what we paid on a given day CPC
the green is what we were trying to pay
as we call it the Skynet target I like
that term anyways
Skynet assault it's the master of our
software the blue the red is what we're
bidding the black is a constraint we
don't want to pay more than that per day
on average we have all sorts of job
information about when we're sleeping
when we're doing smart work when we were
turned off when or day parted this is
actually green it's what we paid and
black is what we wanted to pay and so
forth and so on monthly budgets how many
campaigns are running down here this is
sort of cool graph here that I'm
pointing at which is sort of when you
get to smaller campaigns they become
almost like quantum mechanics compared
to D'Antoni in physics you get really
big accounts you have to worry about how
many clicks you're getting it's sort of
a continuous function when you get to
small accounts for they're only getting
three four five clicks a day you have
discrete States you don't get all you
don't get three and a half clicks get
two you get three might get four you
know from two to four that's a hundred
percent change but it varies the bounces
around there's a lot of we show here in
color rainbow colors the newest ones are
pilot and the oldest ones are red and
then it's rainbow colors in between so
you look at and see what's going on all
this is in support of what we're doing
so we can understand what's going on we
spend a lot of time in these graphs this
dashboard does it enables us to do our
work really well this is all Mathematica
we're constantly making changes to it
what if we do this we have this feature
all these lines you see on here
tell us like the blue the green is when
they change a constraint the black is a
change to budget so forth and so on blue
is they change the number of campaigns
they're currently using this is a much
larger account this is seven hundred
campaigns in it
sharing a budget that's a lot bigger the
last one which had one basically so it's
a very different type of result and so
we want to build to handle all these
cases with the mathematics that we're
doing we look at it different ways like
this this shows red line is before us to
the left here in this graph you see each
month they ramped up their spend per day
which means they were not spending their
budget evenly throughout the month
that's a bad thing I call this the shark
fin a big black peak there and just like
running middle-distance running like
great runner Prefontaine even pacing is
best you don't want to spend all your
money on the last day of the month you
don't run out of money early you want
even pacing therethe month very hard to
do in smaller accounts we're doing in
bigger accounts that's something we're
looking at here and another thing we did
recently which I threw this in for the
fun of it I really like this this is
fairly new research this is greatly
benefiting from Wolfram cloud because we
can scale and go out and do this on
everyone we have hundreds of thousands
of campaigns we do this upon so that
each campaign and we can look at all of
its keywords and all the words they use
in their ads and say what are they
talking about we don't know anything
about these people they might be
categorized by the advertiser yellow
pages somebody like that but I don't
want to trust there and there's there's
different types of things you advertise
upon some things dentists are not
seasonal they just occur all year like
lawyers other things lawn care they're
seasonal so your advertising won't be
constant throughout the year it'll be
peaky in the summer and almost none in
the winter particularly we live in
Wisconsin or Montreal like I did this is
a case where we train on a training set
across the reasonable number of
campaigns and then we went out looking
at the rest
and said with or him classifier and said
what do we see and for this case here we
can see we didn't know who these people
were it said something like I sound like
a resting homes what I thought when I
read it but I didn't know you can see
they're doing mainly physical therapy
then they're advertising a nursing and
rehab psychologist we have some unknown
block there's some keywords we don't
know what they are
might be junk this enables us then to
compare them to other people like kind
was it's almost like you're 23andme DNA
test so now we can tell what you are and
we can then compare you like I something
that couldn't do without the Wolfram
cloud we're gonna do this regularly on
our clients because we never had this
information before it is a good example
of what you can see and that's different
with this type technology versus
previous technology you know people say
well what Big Data projects you just get
more the same well not really this isn't
anything we've seen before conclusions
were able to implement algorithms now
three times as fast as before that's
pretty big deal for us as a company we
can significantly increase number
algorithms we're testing and supporting
before are many algorithms there was one
or two maybe on a good day now we have
like five or more we're testing and so
much of this that we do we can't do it
in any place other than like I said
before production there is no other
environment we've actually gone to a way
I describe it now within the company it
took almost three years to convince our
company of this that it's sort of like
f1 race cars there's RAC testing and
there's track testing you can test the
certain amount on the rack but you got
to put the car on the track and see how
it actually does that's true with us we
have to actually bid actually I actually
had to be in the auction let's see
what's going on
when number three we've been able to
eliminate the non mathematics issue I
think that's a big problem for a lot of
companies this Tulley separates the two
activities scientists do the math
computer scientists do the computer
science it's great I don't want to do
that of the stuff I'm happy to give it
up never really wanted to do it let's
just leverage whoop RAM language
mathematic libraries in production
that's amazing I mean we took like that
classification thing we showed there's
our first cut on that we had within a
few days done all sorts of analyses were
looking at what about this I mean go
test the idea really quickly with
Mathematica notebooks and see what's
going on it's really been a great thing
it greatly extends our post analysis
capabilities that's why I showed a few
minutes ago all those graphs we're doing
that across thousands and thousands of
cases you couldn't do that one by one
take forever and a decouples most the
complex computations away from normal
software cycles and that that really is
one of the key findings here and lastly
it enables us to scale with the web from
cloud and with AWS there's a feature in
AWS some of you might have heard of
called spot market where you can go out
and do bigger computations from 1/10 the
price but you have to agree to certain
things like they might just turn you off
for the fun of it or in the middle of it
but it's one-tenth the cost so maybe you
do want to do once in a while and you
can scale out and so forth as needed
lastly I just want to throw this in
front of you this is a recent Gartner
chart and it shows pretty clearly that
people are looking at this issue
particularly if you look at right here
I'll grow the marketplace
API driven offerings like this or what's
going to drive a lot of good science
across particularly the bids business
industry this is from I think June
something like that this year
we're at the beginning of the hype cycle
which is sort of interesting
and what's also interesting we actually
look at all these things they list here
you can discover the 2/3 of them benefit
from this technology or more that's it
for me any questions
[Applause]